hey guys it's just data today we're
unboxing the brand new DJI Ronin SC this
is a follow-up to the previous Ronin s
what I recently have just been using
quite a lot for a bunch of the shots
that we were filming in Montana we use
this thing a ton I wish that we would
have had this on this chip because this
thing is half the weight of the Ronin s
and the Ronin s isn't even that heavy I
think it's a little bit over four pounds
whereas this one is one point one
kilogram
hey how many pounds is one point one
kilogram one point one kilograms is two
point four three pounds kill point 43
this is less than two and a half pounds
so enough talking let's open it up
because I need to show you guys how
awesome this thing is so the back of
life on this is about 11 hours when it's
fully charged and the payload is two
kilograms hey two kilograms is how many
pounds to kilograms is four point four
one pounds four point four okay so this
thing will be able to handle most
mirrorless cameras and smaller lenses
there's a complete compatibility list
off the link in the description if you
want to see if your lens and body is
compatible most the time when I'm out
using one of these things I'm not using
a massive lens anyway I'd like the
biggest lens that I would be using would
be like the G master 16 235 or the 24 to
70 G master but honestly I probably
would go with just a smaller lens to
make my life much easier so here are a
few cables so these are what allows you
to connect your ronin to your camera so
you able to control the focus and there
is also a little focus motor here and
this has these little grippy teeth too
so this will allow you to manually focus
while you're shooting but to be
completely honest with you
I mostly shoot everything in auto most
the time we're doing like run and gun
shots rarely do we have time to just set
up shots this little handle also doubles
as a tripod which is nice so you can set
your own and down I mean the other one
honestly who's not heavy but in
comparison to this this thing is so
light this is our little battery
charging handle screw this handle into
the bottom here moving on this is what
makes the magic happen this has a
mechanical lock for each axis this is
really great because you basically set
your balance lock it you can put this in
you
backpack or have it set for storage a
difficult thing with some of these
Gimbels is making sure that you're
getting the balance correct so once you
do have it set the last thing you want
to do is continually be messing with it
when you're on a shoot so let's put you
here my gosh this is so much lighter
this is this is just crazy so here is my
oh my gosh this plate is so small this
is big boy Ronan Ronan s and this is the
baby
it's so much lighter
it really is half the weight you'll even
notice this camera plate right here is
so much bigger people give it obviously
the Ronin s is made for bigger cameras
DSLRs with larger lenses but most of the
time the stuff that we're shooting for
YouTube we're using mirrorless we're
using smaller cameras I also like that
this has these little sliders so you can
have this set to where you want the
camera when you're attaching a to the
gimbals
those makes easy because you can just
pop off the camera with the slider
attached and the camera will be able to
go back in the same position when you
slide it back on so this is pretty
awesome
yes we have
little riser plate though sometimes if
you're shooting on a camera where the
lens hangs over the top of the camera so
you need to use something like this to
raise the camera body up from the lens
this is the phone holder so this is kind
of cool because there's a bunch of
different ways that you can mount this
onto the Ronin who can either mount it
onto your camera or you can also mount
it onto the side here one thing that I
first notice is obviously the size of
this case it is so much smaller than the
previous version let me show you oh
somebody went on a summer diet okay so
let's get a camera on this thing and get
it balanced
I'll put big boy away it's so sensitive
[Music]
[Applause]
okay we're in let's do a balance test
[Music]
but tilt is excellent the roll is
excellent the pan is excellent I just
can't even believe it
there's a few new mobile features so you
can connect your phone to the ronin and
you can do active track 3.0 so basically
you can be tracking your subject and
also moving the gimbal around so we'll
be keeping that person or object in the
shot there's also a force mobile feature
so you'll be able to control the gimbal
using your phone so you can have one
person controlling the camera while
somebody else is either holding it and
moving it around so there's a lot of
really cool implementation that I really
want to try out with that I would just
out the force level so when we activate
force Mobile the gyroscopes in my phone
acts as a control or the gimbal on the
camera like look at this I feel like I
am mother I'm enjoying this way too much
I guess I'm going to stop now now I also
want to show you guys the 360 3d roll
this was something that the Ronin s made
these incredible 360 rule shots possible
so you can also do that here you do have
to enable it inside of the app so let me
enable it and I'll show you guys what
I'm talking about there it is this is
gonna be cool
[Music]
we're out about to test out the Ronin SC
and the first thing that I'm gonna tell
you is you can hold a coffee and use the
road at the same time I'm so basic it
hurts look at this
I am so strong or maybe this is so late
[Music]
this is also pretty cool there's a
virtual joystick mode when you go into
the create menu so I can control the
gimbal with my phone this would be
really great if I had an external
monitor attached to it I actually just
recently ordered a little attachment
that you can hook onto here so I can use
the ninja 5 attached to this that hasn't
come in yet but what it does I will do a
follow-up video this is really cool this
is force mobile so basically what this
does is it turns my phone into being
able to control the gimbal this you see
the accelerometer and the gyroscope in
this phone and it is acting like the
gimbal controls do you know what we
could do it could be in the Olympics
synchronized what would we call it think
it like a snake and ice swimming but
synchronized skin bullying
[Music]
you look left and right move a little
there we go
yes that's great good job Jenna active
track 3.0 is so fun the row and SC comes
with this phone mount attach your phone
to the top of your camera get everything
balanced and in the app under the create
section you'll go into active track once
it's open you will select your subject
by drawing a box around them can you
believe this this is so cool I mean my
phone is just attached to it thank you
guys so much for watching interviews
enjoyed this video I look forward to
implementing more fun Ronen SC shots so
far using this thing has been so fun I
love it it's so much lighter than the
previous version made if we would have
had this in Montana no it would have
been great
I know doesn't care about me anymore
makes me feel bad and if you are using
like heavier cameras and different
lenses then obviously the Ronin s is
something that probably would work
better for you but for me this is
honestly everything that I've wanted
I'll see you guys later bye
[Music]